oh is that the reject nation there's no
one here yet it's not the reject nation
there's no one here sup sup sup DMX X
sub locate sup soldiers first private
Sona ah good I'm gonna keep over all
these locate Jacob fills Reis water
women vlogs this for the live streamers
new they just go hey hey hey we're live
I wish I was some half-naked girl in a
bikini so live streams could just be the
easiest thing in the world yeah hey I'm
naked like say that something friendly
enough that I want to talk to them you
gotta answer is how are you doing hey
Jeremiah guys guys we got 49 people in
here just take your shirt off
that's a good Filipino right there then
I'll Sullivan we're not the best
reaction channel there's a reason why
Tyrone Magnus and blasphemous HD and
whomever the [ __ ] you are has more
subscribers because they're the best
they're they're the best don't ever
forget that don't ever forget that never
give us too much credit don't every goes
too much credit works were were cynicism
cynics cynics
hey Jeremy Miller gotta write we're on
our road do are on the road to go see
Kingsman the Secret Service right now
yeah XZ Kingsman the Golden Circle yeah
we're gonna go watch the first one we're
driving our way to go see it yeah we're
gonna go watch kings in the Golden
Circle right now and I wanted to tell
you guys we we couldn't we couldn't
record anything today even though I saw
my phone through certain websites that a
lot of thanks me I'm
more thanks for loving my glasses or
coca-cola brand Tyrone didn't bought
those by those followers don't say that
Tyrone earned those followers with his
Star Wars and Captain America Civil War
reaction all the million of those five
are all one billion such debt well we
had like 49 people watching now we have
24 hey Amy Castle Amy castles here
everyone subscribe to Amy so we were
gonna shoot some videos today but I went
to hit or miss movies a live stream she
lives like an hour away that was fun two
and a half hours on the road and then I
got back and John informing that the
lights went out at our place
well the power went out no power and we
didn't get power on so a little bit
before leaving the road we need get
power anse a little bit before leaving
the road so some trailers are delayed
you know us you know the real rejects
we're not on time we're late to the
party and that's a different channel but
yeah you know I figured woah Joseph fish
fifty dollars for popcorn and drinks
what kind of theater do you think we're
going through my friend gold thanks
Joseph thank you so much damn Joseph
Fisher that's really sweetie incredibly
kind we're gonna buy like for large
popcorns and three large drinks man that
means a lot saying thank you being
negligent by the way the traffic is just
this slow we're gonna we're gonna put
the $50 towards the your fifty bucks
towards uh a bathtub towards the friggin
power literally keeping the lights
turning turning the lights on the film
apparently increases the power bill
exponentially it's crazy
those lights heat up but thank you Joe
so that was really sweet of you I was
and I wasn't expecting that that's
really sweet but yeah I mean since we're
here is only thirteen people watching
now have a go
49:13 this is like the YouTube algorithm
all over it yeah man maybe it just bumps
people off stop watching now stop
watching stop watching prove you want to
hey eggplant the guy with the punk-rock
hairstyle that's John Humphrey mother
effers that's John Humphrey over here
let's see here guy yeah he's wearing a
trick-or-treat shirt right now I got a
red shirt I was thinking of wearing a
suit I'm like it's Kingsman why not wear
a suit to a Kingsman screening but then
I thought it was probably gonna be some
another some more annoying ass youtubers
cosplay gosh man he like this is this
event is through our new rep at
fullscreen a man named Brian shouts out
to Brian Blount dude he's a blunt dude
that guy I like him so far too he keeps
it blunt and he got us these tickets to
go see Kingsman so shoutout to you Brian
for helping us get these tickets
the thing about full screen events that
I'm not a big fan of is meaning other
youtubers don't get me wrong there's a
lot of other youtubers so I just love I
love other youtubers it's just man you
know like some of them are just so damn
fake and they they can't talk about
anything else but YouTube it's and I'm
not looking forward to that that's just
what I'm not I'm looking forward to
meeting some people where I'm sure
they're they're super friendly and super
kind and that you're able to just hang
out with them and talk about life those
are those are the kind of reoccurring
guests you see on the channel when you
have reoccurring guest in the channel
these are people that we talk about live
you're gonna spend all day talking about
YouTube Bailey I want you to know I do
love Chris Stockman I do love Chris
Gutman i watch all those reviews
actually last night we were watching his
review of mother we already bought
tickets to go see mother on Saturday
we're watching Kingsman tonight American
assassin tomorrow so keep a lookout for
some movie reviews coming your ways
well Jeremiah our day's going okay
[Music]
the power went out like I told you guys
like really I didn't realize how
important electricity is running YouTube
channel yeah you can get your desk the
main computer on to edit in all that
stuff only youtubers think should be
talking about ad revenue yeah that's
true that's all we talk about how much
of your income shoot down how much did
your income she last spoke what how much
yeah oh whoa blue Raptor productions
apparently he has a YouTube channel guys
shouts out to blue Raptor Naveen he
wants to know if I play the drums no
this guy does this guy plays the drums a
little bit I'm learning how to play the
drums I'm not good at I don't have my
freedom yet with all my limbs and stuff
Jeremiah I like all the cliche YouTube
mu become movie critics afire where's
the guy who pitched in 50 bucks - this
is a super Chet I want him to ask us a
question whoever sitting that is I will
never take offense to being compared to
a young Rob's the the subscribers I the
the movie critics I love are are the
typical ones man of course the John's
Jeremy Jones he's the [ __ ]
I [ __ ] love man we just got a phone
call with our rep at fullscreen our new
rep and he was like you gotta watch out
for those swear words and stuff it's not
like me to listen to good advice
sometimes you do not give a hoot Jeremy
Jones I love Chris Stockman Jeremy Jones
is great for like those short quick
super quick reviews Chris Stockman he's
like the super intellectual one I don't
really laugh when I watch his videos I
really do I like flick picks reviews a
lot I feel like flick pick actually puts
the most work into his editing
and I can feel that he takes a lot of
time to be you know I feel like it
really makes the effort to make good
solid reviews and I also love you know
sometimes reviews are actually pretty
damn good I really like you know a lot
of people tell me to watch and check out
nostalgia critic I don't really want red
letter media they're my they're my jam
red litter someone just said it I can't
see it
hey see safale yeah they're good DJ hi
says I smoke so much weed you do or DJ'd
I'm not even high right now I just got
here higher or not I just come across
high it's it's just the way I am do i
smoke weed yeah sometimes but either way
I it doesn't matter I look high like no
matter what the video is somebody naveen
do I like jab Iike way I don't like jab
eco a but he's my brother so you know
instinctually I have to love him it's
one of those things you know like liking
is included it's like when you plot like
when you buy like a Kickstarter gift and
you get all the ones below it yeah
Jeremy I would love to see Tyrone
compete in the movie trivia Schmo down
and get dominate you can take our spot
for constantly losing in the road I want
to say late to the party I don't know if
you guys have seen this reaction channel
late to the party but late to the party
I think is really aiding and redefining
you know I don't feel like reaction
channels get as much heat as they used
to is when they first became popular but
I felt late to the parties really
helping and establishing a strong image
I granted their last match wasn't the
most beautiful thing in the world in the
Schmoe down but they've shown and I feel
like whenever John and I play the Schmo
down that we do a pretty damn good job
and though we tend to lose it's still
like we always lose by like a pointer we
always make it to like the final
questions all the time
so we always put up a good match but
late to the party I really feel like I'd
be nervous to play late to the party
late to the party would intimidate
do is destroy yeah Perry movie knowledge
is in the last match wasn't that great
they got TKO'd in the last match in the
second round actually okay but most of
the time man they really know their
stuff hey there's some girl here x.x
Mona Lisa ex as you guys I was pretty
really well she must be a fan of you if
it's a girl she'd probably subscribe for
you thanks Mona Lisa you're the best -
John Tom thanks blue Reaper but yeah
that's uh that's that's my name that's
my name I only want to react to the
Floyd Mayweather Conor McGregor the
lights go back in time yeah go back in
time and put a camera here summer who
watched man I only went out my shades
for you guys going back to the previous
question I only watch movie review
channels with 50 subscribers or less one
the most underground reviews exponent
Lisa X's but Greg you break my heart I
love you - OH
heartbreaker she loves me - meaning she
originally came here for you someone
asked about musical talent I could I
write a lot of poetry I don't really
create music but I like to write poetry
play a little bit of guitar Jeff bears
computer citizen patronage Act one of
our top patrons over at patreon
Tyler we cannot react to the red sparrow
Jennifer Lawrence show they're like we
wanted to earlier because we're on the
road right now to go see Kingsley John
pull over let's do a reaction see the
red sparrow pull it up on your phone not
included in the video and get a lot of
hate
I can react to the knowledge that it's
out yeah really
that's my reaction you guys should go to
the new Queen Mary haunted house maybe
you know Queen Mary kind of lets me down
every year I've been a few times
yeah I were too thrilled by the Queen
Mary yeah it's just like I don't get
scared I maybe I'm just not near enough
to appreciate Universal doesn't really
scare me either but at least they're at
least I admire a lot of universal I
spent it when I go to Horror Nights I
spent my time admiring I think we're
scarier than University I think Queen
Mary can have like a maze or two out of
the 13-day this stuff on the ship is
always great the stuff on the dock is
good it goes back and forth the VM wants
to know how do you deal with haters you
let it sink in take it very you take it
out on everyone you love crush it down
until it bursts forth yes you a friend
or a love you could read fifty love
comments and then one hate comment
ignore all the love and you just let the
hate sink in and then you go that is the
true definition of me hey check out
aggressive comics I like her movie
reviews thanks Mona Lisa aggressive
comics is pretty bomb - yeah I like her
stuff bro not to be offensive but what's
your ethnicity what the [ __ ] dude why
would you ask me a question like that
man
why would you acknowledge this [ __ ]
rude dude I'm Filipino and Italian and
I'm a Virgo someone pointed that out I'm
a Virgo John's of John's Oh Gemini yep
John's Gemini meaning we wouldn't be
compatible in a relationship or some
[ __ ] like a heaven whatever your
horoscope says nostalgia critic I
haven't checked out enough of nostalgia
critic I need to check out more of them
yeah I really was there John about 20
minutes out I'm probably gonna end this
waiting for this can you do an
impression of Batman which Batman are we
talking about were loose
I like to do the face of Batman he has
the mascot you are willing to really
make in the first movie he's like it's
not anyone but then by the Dark Knight
Rises he just [ __ ] exhausted and a
bigram one night he comes home waving a
knife around you do an impression of it
I could do I could do original it hiya
Georgie Georgie I can't really do it
Lorraine ha best impression on a live
stream you want to know how the real
rejects got started we had a sit-down
with YouTube and YouTube was like hey
Greg and John we'd like you guys what do
you think about doing some videos on
YouTube and I said [ __ ] you send your
YouTube I want nothing to do with that
internet [ __ ] then they offered us
$50,000 and we're the only youtubers I
get paid a flat rate up front so we get
a salary no sincere answers here today
off-the-cuff q a road trip John make
sure to watch the guys Gavin Gavin if
you really were a subscriber of this
channel you would see that we did put up
a reaction of downsizing
this guy comes on this livestream list
tells us what's a watch and he doesn't
realize already did it
our are downsizing reaction is hot off
the presses as of yesterday whoa sorry
guys I don't know if this is the same
livestream or not we lost connection
briefly because someone called me snark
that reminds me of freaking Captain cold
on the flag I'm the I'm gonna go after
the Falange
they put me on DC's legends of tomorrow
I like to use my cold gun Miller uh
where's the guy who who pitched in 50
bucks for us to get popcorn and drinks
man where'd he go
just see how that goes straight into our
bank account immediately so I appreciate
that you know we haven't seen narcos I'm
thinking and watching narcos for
watching mother on Saturday
tomorrow's American assassin yeah we're
not like Collider videos who gets all
these awesome publicity hookups to go
see all these movies a week in advance
so we can bag them yeah and you guys
prefer a rack a rack of logs the old
skits I prefer the old skits
I like the rack of rack of vloggers what
I do prefer the skits anytime there's a
sketch I prefer that Jeepers Creepers
yeah we will not do a reaction to
Jeepers Creepers we won't will not
support that movie nope won't do it note
won't do it sorry to tell you my friend
just ain't gonna happen
ain't gonna happen we stand by our word
personal choice you do what you will
yeah you see if I didn't hear about that
I would have done it yeah I'm bummed
it's like I like the first movie before
I found out about all this [ __ ] so hey
yo it's some guy who says we're chill as
hell I ain't true that's not true it's
all a fake personality for you guys
never gon ever blue Raptors that one of
his videos got over 200 views dude
that's awesome celebrate progress man
that's what you gotta do is celebrate
progress that's the key to success Club
celebrate progress strip club
now you're going to the strip I took
John to a strip club not long ago yeah
and then afterwards you you kept going
on about how this is the real strip club
yeah what's it like dumbass strip club
well it was just a different kind of
like one of the strip clubs where there
was like a bunch of people and it's
really packed and all the dances are you
know pretty vanilla
yeah dude I wouldn't want to go that
strip club ever again amen my girlfriend
let me get a lap dance but it's one of
those shitty a strip clubs the lap dance
felt like nothing can we have love strip
one last room and you two that doesn't
mention Trump's orange ass it's so fun I
just mentioned it by reading that
question out loud
yeah you've undone your own request well
we got a very bad connection on YouTube
oh very bad yeah plug up kemo sabe guys
are you there
we're losing you guys come back goldurn
it guys oh dude to heat you can just
filter this to see who contributed money
we're learning this as we go we can't
type on this terrible connection don't
worry as soon as this light changes
why'd you hit the red light John I
wanted this time
Joshu don't worry guys are gonna get
connections can you hear me they can
squeak and still kind of see us
dude we should just do this every time
we drive anywhere we should live streams
dream in the car live stream we should
do this anytime we're not filming a
reaction or a review so that way you
know we never have a personal life it's
always on the internet yeah I want to be
like yeah I'm live all day long I want a
camera in every room in the apartment yo
Greg do you babe do you babe Gretchen I
just saw you vapor I'm sorry wait do you
faith is this a one-time thing
hurry you're gonna do this again at some
point yep I'm still here okay guys uh
Red Hot Chili Peppers is my favorite
band of all time
oh yeah yeah sure that's on another one
of B whoa did you see them [ __ ] on
the road there John there's some [ __ ]
on the road wheezes you know what I saw
the road out mash from top ten versus
team action you and one of the questions
was who said the line high school girls
I love them I keep getting older they
keep getting younger easiest [ __ ]
question in the world next to who
directed from dusk till dawn
Greg getting that bait like fat girls
with tacos hey hey thin girls like tacos
- hey everyone likes tacos
except for that orange dude Donald Trump
you guys I want to give a shout out
really quick I just realized I can
filter this Josef Fischer he's the one
who contributed 50 bucks right now for
us to get popcorn which popcorn and
drinks up they get a man tub and dude
dude and also I'll come on pull it up I
want to see it
I want to see the guy it's so brief and
sahi ball but golf it's a he G I think
that's not I'm saying he said we're
awesome and he could shoot at five bucks
thank you ma'am my friend dude that's
awesome man that's awesome you know
let's see the screen girl we should
donate all our proceeds to helping out
white people who are struggling to not
become lower-class
yeah like me that's the kind of charity
we like to contribute to making sure why
people say the top I'm really glad
you're embracing the white happen I just
really want white people to stay
dominating you know I think they're
doing a great job I think they're doing
a great job I think our because I'm
having a good job you know though some
guy earlier said he's sick of people
complaining about Trump I think you guys
are just in for I think it's just one
giant set up it's like Game of Thrones I
know we got a very bad connection right
now but it's like Game of Thrones you
know first couple seasons it's just
going terrible for the Starks but wait
till his last year he's gonna do a great
job basically Melisandre is gonna make
it so that Obama can come back for a
third term no I think Arya Stark is
gonna be dressed as Kelly and Conway a
girl has president has no name or maybe
no no no Trump is bran the Builder
because he's gonna build the wall you
know and then we're gonna live on
hey guys I got a very bad connection
right now but I wanted to give a shout
out to my lady
my girl
her name is you're the best baby guys
we're losing connection it's terrible
service here in this domesticated area
we should just give our initial review a
Kingsman R after the livestream all
right Kingsman the Golden Circle I
assume is probably pretty fun I'm
waiting for the connection to come back
so I can talk to you guys don't worry
we'll be out of this neighborhood no
sick much time it was like twenty to ten
minutes ago
this time it saved two minutes that is
apart
guys are you still there we lost
connection for a little bit YouTube are
you still there hello you're back
welcome back to youtube.com as you don't
need to donate 50 bucks to keep me high
an eighth is like 25 or I go 25 will be
good damn someone said we're like the
sexiest guys on you it's really hard to
keep up with these comments on a phone
well guys listen we're gonna end this
live stream right now hey my Mariko
you're not invisible I want you to know
which members of the loser club I feel
like I'm the fat kid huh
or Richie John's probably the the black
kid personality-wise or Michael Matt
which one is he
[Music]
Mike well guys I hope you had fun being
on our live streams that we rarely do
know I shout out once again chubby
kidding you're Richie John once again to
Josef Fischer and sahi G Bogle you guys
thank you so much for contributing I
always forget that the super chat that's
crazy I love every one of you guys
except for the racist ones so take care
keep a lookout for a Kingsman review our
American assassin review our mother
review and all the trailer reactions
we've got to catch up on because the
power went out we're not gonna sleep
anymore and people think it doesn't take
any work to do what we do so yeah I
expect all those comments to be like
where the [ __ ] are your videos you watch
YouTube videos all day - shut up
goodbye love y'all
[Music]